but we're talking a lot now Europe what
does it mean what is one of these states
mean what's it good is it a good that
Piraeus is it has been bought by the
Chinese actually was bought five years
ago is that bad what when why is it a
bad if it's a good that there's now a
commercial link between Naples and a
couple ds3 out at the very top of the
Adriatic which is happens to be because
the Chinese are in the Mediterranean and
this happens to be a Chinese container
ship lock so that has leaf story had a
very large agenda continuing working
well how does our next speaker
Joseph Wyler from New York University we
are looking for his property to walk it
or we hope and then felt Scooby coming
and then we hope I put it from a severe
economic spot we'd like very much to
have some focused conversation around
Germany and a broader perspective in the
center but it's not that certain we'll
have to add that conversation this is a
school or this very very important study
of German history and broad broad
perspective and then in the spring we're
kind of will be tending to move some
excuse me here but out we're having
Peter Galison talking about questions
energy we're having mister speaking
about immigration and we will have
another couple of
of speakers so each time we're going to
come a cluster of brats all that said
let me turn the program over to trust
there you will be speaking personally
then hearing and then we'll have to
comment and then we'll keep get picky
things
that's a de Grazia asked me to try and
apply political economy to the European
crisis or difficulties so is
territoriality in this presentation at
some point strong points the sake of
discussion and argument
first of all concerning Europe at the
present analyzing the state of European
affairs today I think including these
that obviously its economic difficulties
it isn't sufficient to analyze Europe as
an autonomous unit I think it has to be
considered increasingly as a subsystem
of global capitalism with some peculiar
systemic regional characteristics and in
general this particular crisis occurs as
three major historical changes are
underway and perhaps I could very great
briefly Asia is obviously emerging as a
set of major economic actors after a
three century period in which it was
eclipsed by Europe we take this now for
granted but it is it is a world
historical transformation and probably
that were forced to choose one that
would be it the United States is clearly
entering a period of uncertainty about
its capacities and Nevada's role after
its brief exuberant unipolar moment from
1989-90 and so we have a long-term shift
in historical equilibrium and this
economic crisis will hasten that ship
matter how it's resolved since it tends
to with the same displacement the trends
are trends but they're also one event
after another that happened to work in
the same direction mostly and I think
that's what's happened the year of
so-called neoliberalism market
regulation seems to be threatened after
its 20-year triumph so to speak since
the collapse of state socialism in 1808
1989-90 but I'm going to suggest that
its actual operating premises with this
understood and they now stand out as a
particular as star formation which I
think it moves us to analyze here comes
that word markets which like thinking it
I said of wonder you know who is a
market and sometimes markets are
supposedly to summation and rationality
Khoa combined and at other times they
seem to be the lemming-like behavior in
which imitative behavior rules so I
whenever I see the market I know adjourn
my judgment on that button now the
prosperity of the last thirty years
twenty thirty years was not only was
built on a real technological change
we should not gainsay that it was built
on going from the age of Steel let's say
to the age of silicon not that steel is
not ceased to be hugely important or
industrial sectors or not moved to be
important the Chinese in nineteen
seventy Purdue
about 20% of a world steel output which
was maybe you have to get 700 million
tons but by 2006 they were producing 45%
of its world steel output that had
doubled so this clearly a lot of
hardware in the last 20 years but at the
same time there is a whole new leading
sector which certainly is transforming
my personal life in the way I've worked
and this is important so age is
reimbursing I think the United States is
clearly in a sense of self questioning I
don't think it's going to disappear as a
major actor but it's you know we talked
about decline and yes in some ways we
are decline it declines though is
relative so perhaps not absolute and
this and neoliberalism is in some
trouble and but we should look at what
it was
now the subsystems I suggested Europe
was part of such system of world
capitalism they are no longer just those
in which trade complementarities tie
together national economies
traditionally the 19th century up until
I think 60s you could say one thought of
systems is where industrial producers
and agricultural producers were linked
together in complementarity one produced
hardware includes in me and the other
commodities there was there was a joint
mutual interest in market interest but
this is less the case there's more there
is differentiation but what's really
these subsystems are regions that
develop complementarities today of
saving and spending behavior and related
to saving and spending the day
export potential and import potential
now once such subsystem is the one which
I looked at in among empires when I
called the United States and Empire
consumption it's the one that Neil
Ferguson is shy America which is a play
of Chimaera America that is a tandem the
duo of the United States and China
whereby China has absorbed and absorbed
a major portion of American sovereign
debt and enabled the United States to
run both large current account deficits
import surpluses crudely put and and at
the same time budget deficits as well so
most of the first decade of the century
was spent having the Chinese fund much
of our budget deficit in return
China gained a good deal of direct
foreign investment the transplantation
of industrial know-how at a large
marketplace for its manufacturers you
know there's rarely a label you can turn
over in a product each stage in a big
store which doesn't say made in China
you have to that you have to go to a
Mercedes dealer so this has been a
mutually beneficial systemic linkage I
think now I would argue European Union
is funded kick came to constitute
another such sub system in which strong
savers and exporters were yoked together
in a complementary relationship with
consumers and importers whose the
pending they have supported Germany
Greece exactly let's give it another
fanciful name to match okay I mention
America let's call it euro Tokyo and the
this is
the system which has functioned on the
basis of those days this mutual but
different types of advantage that are
better game now what's interesting that
each of these systems of courses
regularly denounced in moral terms
repeating in some sense immoral offering
free goods and encouraging dependency
and they're also said to be
unsustainable over the long run now this
is this may be true but the long run is
came to money this can be very very long
Peter Peterson I don't remember for four
decades and said we cannot the United
States is going to say it's a crash
after it's because it's a current
account profligacy well it faced
difficulties but it's you know these
relationships have subsisted over the
decades despite predictions they cannot
last we know in some sense they can't go
on forever but we also know they're not
going to end tomorrow so somewhere
between tomorrow and forever Isis is
involved and the point is that the
creditors in the system the lenders need
the supplicants or the debtors just as
the Dead is need the creditors is what
Keynes tried to teach the Americans in
night
46 we didn't want to listen then and we
played an immoral high card now how does
your Autopia function I don't have to go
over I will go over you know the notion
that it doesn't that it functions in
perfectly because Europe anumana Terry
Union without a political union without
a common fiscal policy is very difficult
and this has been the experiment under
way with that analysis you get everyday
not even the Financial Times but New
York Times and Boston Globe and most
places so ultimately I think that
mismatch may have will be resolved but
despite what the Germans say it
functions to a degree as a transfer unit
and this is I think a good Germany long
designing is going to be an immigration
country long said you're not an
immigration country well it wasn't an
immigration country but it received more
and more immigrants and there is no way
the eurozone could not function as a
transfer a union given Germany desire to
remain a net saver and explore and not
only in Germany the heavy heavy lifters
in this system mark Germany the
Netherlands I could swear Sweden Sweden
and Finland
these are the virtuous pad exporters the
others are more or less balanced and I
don't see any reason it cannot remain in
France for you now this is this room
the electorate of Bavaria may not
approve of this and may change the
balance in the governing coalition just
as a current tea party people in the
House of Representatives many
essentially block the achievement of the
type of bipartisan consensus on fiscal
policy United States but in theory
politics aside that's the biggest side I
think this system can function is it to
transfer Union and in any case whatever
you have the Union like this the
hegemonic factor they're the most
powerful with a political of economic
has to provide public goods to keep the
system going the United States did this
in the Marshall Plan era we were not
transfer Union but we were transfer
stuff to keep Europe to keep Europe
going and to enter into the 1950s the
largest actor has a stake in systemic
stability and so and so should find
intensify massive it was it's the price
of leadership and
we were the lender of last resort and we
were the consumer of last resort now so
it will hear your evening will over as
long functioned as a transfer Union
Germany has made subsidies to French
farmers to sustain the Common
Agricultural Policy which has become a
major cover a sexual pillar of the
European Economic Community any return
Germany received the market for
industrial goods as well as protection
of her own still significant
agricultural producers and the stability
that her leaders understood I think this
is Merkel is she she she knows what to
do it's hard for her to get there and
she doesn't do it with the same cannot
believe it but I think she's been pushed
but the German leaders understand this
so that today the eurozone revoir has
provided the expansion of German and
French financial industries especially
since they are agents their public
utilities in effect that advanced the
funds to the net debtor countries
thereby receiving a de facto commission
so much of this Greek debt of course is
the wrong approach of even though this
is the
by German and French banks and it's for
this reason that the prospect of writing
down its value argue about this I
personally think ultimately allowed to
be written down even if the terms of
repayment or just accepted but in since
Germany this German government can print
them and are trying to protect their own
their own facts and this is where they
get into an argument with mr. Trichet
now the banks have been accused of not
correctly pricing risk of being reckless
and indeed many of these facts happening
but the fact this was assistant in which
the eurozone states were supposed to
eliminate we were encouraged to
encourage to be reckless about mortgage
lending
just a few years ago yeah
this brings me this looking at the
mechanism brings me to the historical
dimension in which euro Tokyo was
created and the so-called
crisis in market liberalism which has
followed the crisis of state socialism a
quarter century ago they tried very
quickly the triumph of market liberalism
was signaled by the election of Margaret
Thatcher that are wrong Reagan in the
French Socialist abandonment of their
redistributed program in 1983 to stay in
the EMS analogous changes took place in
Italy the central bank received its
independence and waging vexation was
brought down and it's incensed this
system what happened the special period
through the end of the seventies with
electoral disillusion of that political
efforts is to contain an inflation that
is wait livable wage bargaining wage
price control Wars etc so what happened
with the the exponents of market
solutions scored a surprising victory
none of us Keynesian economists in the
60s or scented this it seemed just
totally impossible in the major large
labor unions but the labor unions were
to be dismantled apart we transformed
and we entered this period of what the
right tended to call neoliberalism well
I don't think that is quite there the
right term what happened if we look and
I
numbers are wild time when are you going
to them what happened was that the
social actors the financial communities
rescue leadership and the trade unions
and others consented to a compression a
tourniquet of money supplies in the end
of the 1980s public money supplies into
the 1970s as the price actuation but in
return what was less realized was that
in a sense the whole financial community
of each of these countries was given the
right to print private money credit card
expansion investment going into
commercial bagging to investment acting
eventually the king of interest rates is
to sustain the equities markets and we
can see that we look at my money
aggregates or the financial debt he was
dead that is not the debt banks of the
banks but the debt to fund activity
elsewhere whether mortgages are
industrial expansion rose tremendously
in the 80s and world foreign direct
investment inwardly directed rose 1.3
trillion
in the 90s the banking assets groups and
Mendeley banking process group
tremendously the US banking sector and
this is not so different from the youth
or the UK banking sector had been
roughly I have its assets in its assets
on our loan total of about fifty percent
of national income and the assets were
about half that amount from 1850 to the
mid 60s for over center then they
climbed to a hundred percent during the
seventies and then to two hundred and
fifty percent by the end of the 1980s
and about five hundred and fifty percent
on the eve of the crash of 2006 and this
is by greatly increasing leverage love
the profits in other words we went from
a system of prime public funding of
social bargaining in the seventies to
assist in a private vast private credit
expansion and paper assets monetary
monetizable asset expansion in this
period returns on bank equity on back
stocks jumped from 10% perfected to you
through that 20 percent and enough for
30 percent so this is a this is a huge
unleashing under state offices in each
countries and the euro zone's and other
some degree under the Basel agreements
of the fraud of private credit and
monetary asset creation and it was what
the world woke up to this in 2006 to 8
to 8 woke up to it in relation to the
more American mortgage market now that's
often depicted as a bunch of shiftless
people wanted to buy homes that they
could not afford but it was all but just
as equally it was it was a result of
banks pushing money into this system and
not only directly into housing but then
you know derivatives based on these
mortgages which were sliced and diced
and sold all over and then even more so
credit default swaps which are
essentially just bets on the outcomes of
the way investments will turn out
no there were bubbles there were
Corrections the crash of 1987 which was
quite drastic the Savings and Loan
collapse in the United States the
dot-com collapse in the early 2000 the
failure of long-term capital management
but by and large these were sustained in
part because the crises could be laid
off on the developing merging market
world Mexico had a major crisis Thailand
and a major crisis since this is the way
the gold standard had operated before
the first world war
so underneath these phenomena it was
also a major change in what we could
call the regulatory parameters of
capitalism that is monetary policy
financial policy tends to policymakers
look at a one overriding index to which
they orient themselves like a a
lighthouse on the horizon that changes
in before and the interwar period it was
up to the you worker it was the gold
standard in other words you tried to
stabilize it run an economy according to
with these brands of gold or not from
your country this seemed to lead to the
great contraction of the 1930s at the
end of World War two we went to a
complicit full employment standard
policy was wrong to keep employment up
the left was stronger after World War 2
in Western Europe fascism it collapsed
this see this this work until 1981 I
think under the night under the Bush
administration we we actually went
toward a sort of implicit equities
market standard of regulation Alan
Greenspan would pump that would keep the
interest rates low enough to sustain the
buoyancy of these markets and then
worried about irrational exuberance it
wasn't irrational it was
so this is the system now today we look
at the ratio of debt to GDP I'm not
saying these are all totemic or false
but they are we have to look at the
implications for them and have their
change now this system is in crisis I
think Europe as a additional reason
beyond the United States they're worried
and that's it's it's demographic
composition the lack of replacement of
active labor force participates by non
labor force participants and as let me
just end by with a couple of theoretical
reflections the ground rules of
capitalism decompose economic returns
into assets or savings into consumption
in theory savings exists to facilitate
future consumption but in fact for those
who can say you're a witness to
consumption Kansas savers and I need big
saviors save because small savers they
like to say they accumulate which is
what Marx notice what he called the law
of Moses and the prophets theory I don't
believe I can see their regular
economics at Percy
but the notion of an aggregate
consumption preference for consumption
propensity to consume or to save seeing
the mathematically related seems to me
miss perception of what happens there
there is no one socially aggregated
propensity there are at least two deeply
rugged social preferences which have
their political expressions those who
say because they can they will sometimes
because they must because they just
can't consume enough after you have your
forty million dollar home when your
yacht etcetera etc
stuff piles up they save because they
can if we don't worry must and then
should consume because they must to have
a little choice this is and usually
these divided between the left and the
right and the left
although the politics is modeled because
many of the social actors like trade
unions and educated left-wing educators
say through pension pockets and now in
periods of asset pricing or destruction
people wake up that they consume a huge
amount of stuff which which pricing did
not let them see this happened active
the war Awards vast amounts of physical
destruction the World War one it had not
been priced into the system and when
people woke up to this it caused it
cause rapid currency appreciation in
periods of eccentric pricing or
destruction the choice has to be to
privilege assets and saving or privilege
consumption consumption is almost always
sacrifice because of the central role
that accumulative agencies the savings
agencies have been given a Greek
consumption will fall because German and
French assets need to be safeguarded now
I'm not saying it shouldn't fall but I
will but these would be the crisis
operates to these consumers can become
systemically threatening only by
catastrophic developments whether
through suffering that's suffering as in
Argentina in other places for a while
or through Street Theater and violence
asset managers are systemically
threatening all the time because their
assets are needed to the circulation of
the system cohesive classes don't really
exist necessarily labor wants to defend
its accumulated assets and pension funds
as well as yet as well as being able to
consume but the sectors of the economy
are created still try to think it's
great not just buy class with like
different attitudes toward intertemporal
t toward the present and the future an
economy maximizes the future for the
present in fact in a closed economy one
can't live off of one's grandchildren
that's impossible there are production
frontiers in the present and so to
appeal to the future is to give
priorities to those institutions that
can save at the cost of present
consumption and state socialism did this
all the time the economy of state
guaranteed asset accumulation which is
what the neoliberal experiment was state
guaranteed asset
elation trying to satisfy both
priorities through real roads it did it
had the benefit of working at a time
when we had this great technological
revolution and it tried to give the
consuming classes more access to housing
as an asset and as a consuming good in
the United States certainly but the
shift in economic power has thrown this
into doubt and the reality of the growth
seems that now that's where I think we
are the accreditor is deemed to have a
virtuousness that being a debtor does
not and of course my commentator was
stepped in after a government had
behaved rather profitably the dining
that the future would make a claim but
by the Pirandello quote the one in
English you know what is it right you
are if you think you are to get the
Italian title in the play but I would
say rich you are if you think more and
for you are to think you aren't rich so
we come to deeply rooted individual
psychological and personal attitudes as
well as as well as class behavior and
what I think economics has not really
systemic Lee thought through since the
days of Witsell and Austrians with the
ratio relationship of the future
Salon economist Thank You Vicki that the
book she was referring to just in case I
forget to mention that I just say is the
basis of this talk although a lot has
happened since that was public Aikido
was only about seven months ago actually
publicly in Lombard Street from
Princeton Press if you want to look into
the background of some of these
arguments will be maybe so I want to
think about our table Europe Europe is
ground zero today yesterday this week
but the United States was ground zero
four years ago I refer of course to
August 2007 when the US crisis began
followed by the bear stearns collapse in
March 2008 and dead women in September
2008 it might be in that context that us
contact is essential for understanding
the current moment in Europe as I shall
relate there are strong similarities
between the two crises indeed I would go
so far as to say there two aspects of a
single ongoing crisis which is playing
out differently in Europe than in the
u.s. because of different historical and
institutional contexts to begin I want
to draw your attention to the
extraordinary actions of two central
bank's the Fed and the ECB and petal to
see there are many many close parallels
between what I have to say and what
you've what you just heard but one thing
I will say a lot about that we didn't
say a word about a single banks
Tucson the banks the Fed NBC D which
have used their own balance sheets to
put a floor on the crisis this I want to
sort of emphasize it is the simple banks
that have saved the vacant episode so
far okay they won't tell you that
because they're not sure that it was
it's legal but that's what they did
other central banks have also been
involved the Bank of England the Swiss
National Bank the Bank of Japan would
leave them decide
and their time they get becoming will
come to that discussion in previous
history only in wartime and as a support
with ardent war finance have central
bank's expanded their balance sheets in
the way we've seen in the last four
years and it's not over yet this new
role of central banks raises a number of
questions which can only be engaged by
bringing back political economy
I see three lines of inquiry immediately
first ticket is given the legitimacy of
extraordinary central bank intervention
to support when working as you're
fighting a war the central bank is a
subunit of Treasury and the story we've
seen that before in both world wars and
also farther back at that but today
where's the war this time we are
currently stating not democracy or
sovereignty or anything of that kind but
rather the financial system and
sometimes even individual banks the
central bank is using the tremendous
power of its balance sheet not in its
role as government bank but rather in
its role as a banker's bank
it's a new thing is it illegitimate them
first second question
ticket is given that central banks took
on this extraordinary world role only
reluctantly perhaps people don't realize
that but yes simple bankers are actually
rather conservative figures they don't
want to do this only reluctantly and
because other more legitimate policy
tools and policy actors were frozen the
Fed acted because Congress prevented the
Treasury from active the ECB acted
because there is no European Treasury
and the European financial stability
facility the nearest equivalent is too
small put more pointedly the central
banks after because the political
leaders did not is that legitimate and
what does it say about the legitimacy of
the political leaders in taking on this
task central bankers were active in
cooperation with other central banks and
thus in effect as supranational actors
it is a global financial system that
they were saving not the national
financial system and yet all central
bankers are at least on paper
sabore them to their domestic political
masters for lack of action by the g7
much less than g20 we've got world
government by the c-5 the Bank of
England the ECB the Swiss National Bank
the bankers and the central banks how
should we think about this emerging
unelected unaccountable government
remember they saved us a complicated
relationship to this so I can talk about
central banks and I've hung these three
points on the role of the central bank
but the broader political economic point
touched by each of the three concerns
the relationship between private finance
and the nation-state the central bank
having a foot in each of these worlds is
a natural focus for this broader concern
but it's only a piece of a larger story
as an illustration of that larger story
I draw your attention to the front page
of yesterday's Financial Times two
stories of dinner two headlines one US
tax authorities target Bank feels this
is an article about how private finances
facilitated tax avoidance far place the
big banks are all involved in this
second headline JP Morgan head W Jamie
Dimon lashes out over anti American Bank
regulations this is an article about the
clash between Jamie Dimon and Mark
Carney was governor of the Bank of
Canada and the presumptive next head the
pages to do
for our which is the international group
of regulators all of these headlines are
indications of a fraud character of the
current relationship between private
finance and the nation-state the old
loan system has broken down like we have
provocative introduction so let me build
this argument a bit at its core and I
think this is where customer and I agree
maybe this crisis is really about
financial globalisation old words are
important to me when I say globalization
I do not mean primarily trading goods
and services but rather the integration
of previously national money markets in
capital markets again both words are
important securities markets are
increasingly global as cooler than
vegetable capitals seek out the highest
risk adjusted return on individual
investments but also on diversified
portfolios of investments from around
the world and money markets are also
global as national borrowers who seat
more funds than domestic lenders are
offering
inevitably find what they need in global
funding markets global funding markets
especially dollar funding markets given
the special role of the dollar financial
globalisation in the last 30 years has
created the modern world and it is being
tested to the court by the current
crisis now being is smaller crises of
financial globalization were typically
triggered by funding problems narrowly
in peripheral nations think of Mexico or
East Asia typically a piece involved a
combination of currency crisis as well
as banking crisis because the lending
was in dollars and the currency risk was
back stopped in one way or another by
the state just so typically the agents
of deliriant of the age of deliverance
from these crises was usually sucked
from beneath
the IMF and the United States the closer
you were to the United States the better
off you were one exception and a key
turning point in what in my view was the
long-term capital management crisis of
1998 even that was understood by many as
simply a consequence of the Russians and
enterprises just another funding problem
and a peripheral nation in retrospect
however involves something new long-term
capital management was a hedge fund
doing swirls called convergence trades
which meant trading both long and short
in global capital markets and it was
funding those trades in global money
markets to my mind LTCM was the first
crisis but the emerging market based
credit system often call today the
shadow banking system I remember that
well that was the fall of 1998 I had
just recently finished writing
intellectual biography of Hyman Minsky
and I was teaching economics of money
inventing so as the crisis I've rolled
onto the pages of the Financial Times I
found it naturally ask myself what would
Minsky say at the time as a test to see
this man that's why I got started I'm
just really thank you the long term
credit the long-term capital management
crisis was resolved essentially by
wiping out LTCM security holders and by
forcing us other creditors to take an
equity stake all the while the Fed the
Fed didn't do any of that it held a
meeting downtown okay but the Fed
intervened to maintain stability in the
domestic dollar money market generally
and that translated the stability of the
world dollar my market it was scary
there for a while but everything held so
far so good
we got overconfident thought that's what
prices are going to look like in this
new world of global
financialization wrong the retrospect
long-term Pecola manager was just a
little 45.0 warning shock and today
we're in the middle of the 8.0 main
event unlike LTC how the current crisis
is going to be on private balance sheets
and it's taken the form of a fiscal
crisis of the state both in the US and
in Europe it's important to appreciate
the state was never supposed to be the
backstop for the market-based credit
system so-called shadow banking in the
u.s. the private banking system was
supposed to be the backstop okay but the
city banking but II got overwhelmed and
that's how the state backstop got into
the picture and Europe like contrast the
state was already in the picture because
most of the bank credit was already on
the balance sheet of the private private
banking system they did shadow banking
all on their on their balance sheet UBS
in the United States the underlying
securities were household mortgages in
Europe the underlying securities are
sovereign debts in both instances a good
chunk of the debt was funded short-term
money markets that so when the prices
hit in both cases the first approach
taken by central banks involved
intervention in the money market this is
natural to central bankers okay ever
since Walter Paget's Lombard Street 1873
Lombard Street which is a description of
the money month lemon money market a
book by the way which everyone can read
okay and everyone should read even
though it's about the monetary
institutions of 19th century Britain and
so it's completely out of date it's
torture money markets only but it is
essential reading if only to compare
with the present that's the book where
central bankers they've got their mantra
in a crisis led three against would
collateral and at a high rate and that's
what central bankers tried to do when
this crisis broke over all central banks
did but both soon found out that it
wasn't enough the problem was that the
modern the modern financial system is
really much more of a
it's in a money market system the
problem was with the collateral for this
therefore the collateral in both cases
long-term debt quite different from the
kind of short-term trade credit it was
the focus of Paget's analysis liquidity
crisis showed itself not only in a
sudden demand for money which is like a
bank knew how to deal with okay but also
in sharp Falls and security prices
hence rising haircuts for the securities
offered as collateral the market for
secured funding froze up because the
lenders of money did not want to risk
getting stuck with the illiquid security
collateral that's some jargon
understanding here's the important point
they don't report include quick anomic
for understanding this dynamic or
learning this dynamic theme the crisis
both the Fed and the ECB responded by
extending their traditional lender of
last resort we meant to include also
what I call dealer last resort hence the
title of they intervene that only in the
money market but also in the capital
market directly by buying particular
class of securities whenever their price
fell too far below what the central bank
considered to be a fundamental value
this is I can't explain enough to you
this is how traumatic this is how how
how what a deviation is this from what
the Fed thinks it should be doing okay
it never would have imagined in a
million years that it would be buying a
truly knowledge with a mortgage for
Artest securities and get in a crisis
that's what it wound up doing the Fed
was slower than ECB any quat
mortgage-backed securities need to be
bought sovereign debt directly and
and it still is the point is that
central bank central banks became not
only bankers banks but also dealers
dealers they move directly into the
capital markets and got completely
intermeshed with financial globalization
as we're focusing tonight on political
economy I should emphasize that both of
that and the ECB were careful about what
securities they bought in the US the Fed
bought mortgage-backed securities at
Hussle mortgages have a long history of
special treatment Fannie and Freddie in
the u.s. so it could be argue that the
Fed is simply building on that history
rather than deviating from its own
history and you're upsetting the ECB
want peripheral sovereign bonds but
again the whole European Union project
of all special treatment for its members
so maybe again it could be argued that
the ECB was simply building on that
history rather than deviating from its
own what I'm suggesting is that
immediately the intervention of the
central bank can be justified as an
extension of his accepted legitimate
role as a government bank there's a case
there but that case fails to explain why
people are so upset if it's really just
Fannie Mae plus okay why are people so
upset I think we have to take onboard
that central banks have been doing
something dramatically new they've been
doing more finance to save Private
Finance and we need to understand what
that means for our future in the US
there are three bogeymen the candidates
were office reliably trot out to enflame
both in fleeing the voters big
government is one we hear a lot about
that but also big finance Americans
think big food and also the big wide
world
the wife trots out the government the
left cuts out big finance and they've
all tried out the big wide world
Lenin to sport big banks was bad enough
but letting to support the European
banks will simply be on the tail you
might remember how Congress rigged Ben
Bernanke or the coals on that line and
he learned that lesson that means that
Europe is going to be
more on its own as this crisis continues
to enroll the Fed will be unable to help
last week Operation Twist is about as
much as Ben Bernanke feels he can do
so suppose Greek Greece defaults which
is looking pretty likely so what'd you
say Greece is not very big and it's not
actually but the senior member was said
but about by me about the subprime
worship halls in the fall of 2007 very
summers for example said that there
aren't so many it is it's only 250
million dollars forget about the problem
in both cases is at least these assets
were not simply owned outright by
someone who we just have to absorb the
loss that ownership was also were
awfully not funded by borrowing in world
money markets the struggle in a very
small section of world capital markets
got transmitted immediately into the
general world money market and fear a
looming trouble became itself trouble
since it produces the very contraction
of credit
that's feared as a consequence of
outright default debt overhang
deleveraging and credit contraction are
the headwinds preventing growth today
soca nature globalization has been the
theme of world growth for the last three
decades financial deep localization
could well be that the overworld
contraction for the next decade those
are the states deleveraging is an
enormous headwind as I said but behind
that edwin is an even more enormous
political economic problem the shift in
relationship between private finance and
the nation state
thank you very much good evening I
started my studies on economics in 1986
the university that I started to study
was called Karl Marx University of
Economics in Budapest and then I
finished five years later in 91 it was
already called Budapest University of
Economics to say the university's name
yoga and the statue of comets is still
there today which is probably a sort of
precaution in that part of the world we
are used to so many changes it's not
worth throwing out those you things they
may become use and when this crisis hit
there was a lot of debate whether you
know this is the crisis of capitalism
and having learned my lesson in the late
eighties early nineties I said to myself
what we have learned if you have heard
it many times in debates is the visit
capitalism is in constant crisis I think
this right now we all agree that this is
a crisis in capitalism one of the men
eager have happened in the past but
crisis in capitalism according to one of
the Rockefellers like to quote all these
quote classics now is that capitalism
was built on trust and I think in the
last decade what we have seen is that
the has a balance between greed and fear
which keeps capitalism more or less
under control has been so far and so
long doubt in the direction of greed
that when the pendulums went back fear
has been riding our life and will be
driving for quite long in the coming
years
and that is that loss of trust which is
shaking the flu
because of the economies in Europe and
in the United States and you do for a
while now this is the global message of
this crisis but I think these crises
have proved to be proven to be a very
uninvited an unpleasant guest in every
country and every region in the world
and it has been delivering a message to
each and every country on a tailor-made
ways and what this crisis has delegate
as a tailor-made personal message to the
European Union that the European Union
is in crisis because it has been going
through half-hearted have considered
have explained and have finished
integration this is the crisis of
European integration Europe the European
integration is half finished because
Europe is doomed always to make sub
optimal decisions when it comes to major
decision points suboptimal because
Europe is working on the principle of
the commonly the smallest common
denominator of 27 countries they always
try to agree on political points of
decision they trying to find a consensus
among very different interests of small
and large states of different economic
and political culture and development
but they try to make a decision
they run ahead on those issues where
they can agree and leave behind those
unresolved issues where they cannot
agree and therefore they always come to
somewhat suboptimal decisions at the
given four
and the best example of the European
monetary union that was a suboptimal
decision because neither benefit of
hindsight they can't easily say that the
stupid to create a monetary union
without the fiscal unity that cannot
work long term there were many people
who said that at the time but there were
many many positive reasons value of G an
integration had to have including a fear
over the United Germany arguments to
create a single market in a more
efficient way etcetera etcetera and
those positive motivations have pushed
down those arguments which were
announced eagerly on that is the
creation of the system is suboptimal and
it will not work there because the
monetary union cannot work without the
fiscal union but not only at the
inception but ever since many mystics
were coming to let in Greece in on the
basis of for statistics France and
Germany by routing in 2003 the
Maastricht criteria which weren't very
wise anyway and the whole system was
created on the principle which now shows
its impossibility which very often the
German position is in this debate is no
exit from the European from the eurozone
no bailout because we are not the
transferor Union and no default so there
can deceive with the system the dear
ozone was created as fair-weather
alliance of countries without planning
for short but the storm is always
the storm is coming and show and
creating hurricanes in different parts
of the system
what started as a bank crisis has become
a sovereign crisis of excessive debt and
deficits but there has been a
fundamental crisis which was there
before which was real opium
competitiveness on the ground or slope
before the crisis all these crisis has
shown the incapability insufficiency of
the European governance structures all
this has now become the crisis of our
political union to a degree is the
political billion and today what we see
is clearly a political crisis one of my
former colleagues John Toluca who is not
only Prime Minister about Luxembourg but
he's also head of the eurozone has said
the key motto of this crisis today which
is we meaning the European leaders we
all know what we need to do what we
don't know is how to get reelected if we
do what we need to and this is
symbolizing the problem and I wouldn't
like this to be translated simply as an
agency problem of politicians who very
likely to serve the public good but they
are rather motivated by their personal
interests of getting very likely this is
not that or not only that this is also
the difficulty of European leaders to
get the very skeptical public to
legitimate legitimize and accept
fundamental shifts and changes in
giving the observable energy because
what Europe is about is an
unprecendented
attempt to create synthetically for the
Federation from historical existing
strong identity-based the national state
it's an unprecedented trial explain
explain even which we don't know whether
if you succeed so this is a political
crisis if you talk about the current
situation at least three questions
toward four questions to be raised one
is there anybody any country and a
leader in Europe in the past 20 years it
has not committed mistakes that were
needed to distrust and the answer is
really no everybody was involved in this
every country but not only those who are
the consumers importers but also the
exporters are saviors major instance the
second question can we realistically
expect Germans citizens to write a blank
check for profligate countries in the
indefinite future you know that is that
was the famous I don't know how many of
you follow soccer but that was Gary
Lineker a genius UK striker who after
game they lost in the quarterfinals of
One World Championship said you know
football is a game we're 22 men chase
the ball and always the Germans mean
this is the principle now what we see
today is the Revenge of the in vineger
principle because the eurozone seems to
be a football teacher 37 nations play
and always the German speak of the bill
and it is quite understandable by German
City
do not want to pay the bill in that
minute future
so when Minister finance is the child
that says you can talk about euro bonds
only after there is a proper proper
fiscal decision-making structure a
strict prudent fiscal decision-making
structure it's quite understandable
money talks about them but a third
question of political bill that we need
to raise our political issue is can we
realistically accept Greek citizens to
accept to go into a tunnel that they
know for sure that that tunnel has no
other exit at the end because it is
quite obvious for everyone that Greece
cannot and will not be able to repay its
current level of funding than 50 percent
of GDP I don't think you can
realistically ask people to take
unlimited suffering into the future
without having at least beacon of hope
at the end of the tunnel and we have to
say please his bankrupted a the Greece
has to restructure without restructuring
he Greece will not be able to cope with
its garbage trucks at the fourth
fundamental political question we have
to ask is is that alternative to
eurozone or what is the alternative of
breaking up that politically relevant
question has not been raised enough
everybody at many European leaders are
trying to swim with the waves of
populism instead of trying to explain to
their citizens what is the cost
after the first attempt that I have seen
last week I don't know how that that
funded that is what UBS researchers at
UBS not the traders I've issued a report
on what would be the cause of great of a
breakup of the eurozone and they said if
Greece departs alone in the first single
year after the party maneuvers and they
would take a hit between 40 to 50
percent of GDP if Germany departs the
eurozone according to UBS analysts they
would suffer in the first year of
departure he took between 20 to 25
percent per day which is an unthinkable
even a half of his numbers is true yet
disclosed to see the role in these
factors I'm talking from a position of a
former prime minister who had to cut 5%
of GDP on the coast side of the budget
from one year to another he survived it
we stabilized the economy but that was a
tremendous strain but 15 20 25 percent
reduction in GDP or 40 to 50 with France
angel
so only economically from from the many
economically sound positions to solve
this crisis only those would work in
Greece Germany and overall in which from
the political economic point of view and
I believe professor speaking before me
political economy is back with a
vengeance not only those would work
which are looking at his political
aspect of what is what can be considered
just for both sides of the debate I've
just run after the moped I don't know
very publish it on on one such solution
which the first to save the bank by
recapitalizing plans returning EFSF into
a european monetary fund but then
introduced the mechanism of forced exit
into the eurozone for the future not for
the past a forced exit pull out from the
eurozone for those who will become
profligate in the future that would be a
guarantee for Germans and other northern
European sailors and exporters that in
the future they can get rid of those in
an orderly and quick way who are free
riding and there at that cost but on the
other hand this package of solution
should also mean saving Greece and
restructuring Greece within the euro
zone cutting out roughly half half of
their death conditional basis agreeing a
ten-year restructuring and austerity
program which brings them out of of
their current stage it means that backs
the gross which will still be very fun
so this sort of solutions can make sense
which help political leaders to explain
to their over the answers vibe in the
future we will not commit the same
mistakes and why that is full but even
if these solutions are found Europe can
only get out of this crisis of
integration by going for the founding
fathers of a different foundation points
of the European Union as I explained
with all always find sub optimal
solutions to the to the problems of the
day but because they understood those
problems are suboptimal they always
found or established structures which we
behaved like a fool you cannot pull them
out there is no exit from the eurozone
there is no exit from Europe practically
there is only way forward and they have
to zero to find solutions
crisis to its problems always in crisis
under the pressures of crisis and so I
am convinced Europe will go ahead from
this crisis and if I would need to bet
my money even on a rational choice I
would bet on Europe to survive and go
ahead bit more integration from this
crisis but even if they resolve this
crisis of physical and financial
problems you know it will immediately
bound to face the next major crisis
which will be of European legitimacy
because if you centralized fiscal policy
then you centralize and raise to the
European level
the most fundamental issue of politics
the heart of politics which is how much
money you take from the citizens of a
country or a region and how much money
you give back to other citizens that is
the heart of politics and if that is
race or control or decided to a
logically increasingly large extent in
Europe then the legitimacy of European
policymaking has to be raised compared
to the participation as long as we get
that European leaders have three
obligations we are facing very tough
environment in the coming 10 years major
challenges looking lady of the fiscal
classics of competitiveness and
austerity and reform at the same time
but the responsibility of European
leaders is threefold first they have to
make sacrifice as short as possible
without making political curves too much
and prolonging the transfers second they
should avoid making unnecessary
sacrifice because there is already
enough pain that we're coming to the
system
but above all the biggest responsibility
of everybody who is a leading a leading
position decision making position is to
make all this sacrifice worthwhile
because there is a big challenge with
risk but at the end of this role of
sacrifice there is a better working
my main - the fact that you talk
function
no comment Authority and 30 men
underscore the fact that the European
Central Bank Act is because there is no
European Treasury combined I just said
we are facing a crisis of European
integration in we're witnessing monetary
union but no fiscal union and I would
like comment on these
to the lack of a commentary to the fact
this is a political crime I think you
should consider that in many cases the
monetary union was not conceived as the
ultimate goal of the process but rather
as an impermanent expect awarded
stronger and deeper political and
economic Union and idea behind the
monetary union was that you can
countries with with a free to wear a
self-imposed the straitjacket to which
will force them to adopt a common
monetary discipline and this in turn
further step toward political education
we often hear the remark that the
historical peculiarities of Europe and
of the Bureau is that we have a single
currency without having a single state I
often hear his remark with a visit idea
or hope that was a political single
entity will follow soon and in other
words I think that it was pretty clear
that the monetary union and own
unattainable over a long period unless
political union stronger than
putting place in this sense we could
consider the process of establishing a
monetary union is in a unbalancing step
that everything time in forces you refer
to to to make an average that from the
political side to other humans analogous
other processes of economic and
political partition in the fifties
proposed an analysis of economic
development is fundamentally imbalance
where specific changes of innovation at
the Fairness Act or original level of an
economy would create a critical
situation that would force further
changes in the economic system and for
human this was a series of linkages that
would move I had this process of
economic development to a series of
imbalances and this model became pretty
famous and for me it was used also in
different Sciences
in the social sciences huge man disgust
is model in the fifties and then I
discussed it again with regard to Europe
in the seventies and eighties but it's
interesting that in the fifties were
discussing this about economic
development in less developed countries
and has in Europe was proposing similar
consideration about the process of the
European unification treaty of rome in
sign just one year before in 1957 and
has spoke instead of linkages of
spillover effects focusing on the new
economic institutions that had been
established by the Treaty of Rome such
as the new return or the common market
and predicted now importantly that the
growth of the political community can be
safely projected from the work of these
new economic institutions he also said
that he also wrote that it being
conceivable that if they deliver leave
the trade liberalisation at among
European countries would go on for long
without harmonization of general
economic policies spilling over into
other economic and political fields in
Europe and concluded and working again
the spillover may make a political
community of Europe in fact even before
the end of the liberalisation process
again I think that pass was proposing
something very similar to that imbalance
process analyzed by here in the fact
then critical tensions arising from in
economic
from the process of economic unification
that would force further progress in the
process of political unification of the
country I think it's a matter of during
the 60s the process of unification snow
tunnel but for example in at the end of
the seventies the establishment of the
system if you write that as a reaction
to stagnation of growth the inflation
and rising unemployment in Europe I just
like to make a question too because I
think these models these patterns are
useful to the process of unification in
Europe for the fifties the sixties and
the seventies I'm wondering if you think
they can be useful today if they are
also in a sense of an optimistic
optimistic analysis because from crises
and imbalances that they predict that we
would reach further and better
equilibrium and I have a second question
just related because after all these
factors 432 we have actors that are able
to make the necessary steps to go beyond
a situation of crisis and is equipped to
reach
not just economic and monetary union and
I wonder if you think that we have now
in Europe strong enough as a political
leadership with that is strong enough
and vision have enough and credible NASA
to move ahead of the curve you say and
and bring the euro cooperative economic
a life as I said that you would meet
them trances and that's it for my
comments people making me we need to be
those of space